so what do you think
wow
it's for you right
it's for both of us don't go away
don't worry there's not enough blood
left in my legs to go anywhere
hey it's charlie
do your thing when you hear the beep
listen you lousy sob i will not be
treated like this either you call me or
you are going to be very very sorry i
love you monkey man
charlie
who is that
damn telemarketers
a telemarketer who calls you monkey man
i'm on some weird list
okay it's a woman i went out with once
and she got a little clingy you are a
bad bad boy and yet you're always the
one getting spanked
jeez
hey it's charlie do your thing when you
hear the beep
uh charlie it's alan
your brother
no big deal uh just wanted to touch base
my my wife threw me out and i'm kind of
losing the will to live so when you get
a chance i'd really love to oh i don't
know
hey alan i'm sorry to hear about that uh
so we're gonna go to a hotel wow
huh
well yeah i i guess you could
stay here
okay
i'll see you when you get here
we better hurry
oh is she staying over cause i may have
parked behind her
[Music]
12 years and and she just throws me out
i mean what was the point of our wedding
vows until death do us part who died not
me not her
how did you get in my house
okay charlie the key in the fake rock
only works if it's among other rocks
not not sitting on your welcome mat
excuse me but if you put the fake rock
in with a bunch of other rocks it's
impossible to find when you're drunk
yeah you know i'm a good husband i'm i'm
faithful is she is she what
faithful
don't be ridiculous i mean judah doesn't
even like sex i mean all she kept saying
was she feels suffocated you know she
kept going on and on i'm suffocating i'm
suffocating what does that mean you know
as a woman ever said that to you
well yeah
but not a woman who doesn't like sex
and and and jake this this could just
destroy jake
jake
my son
oh yeah teenagers are pretty
sophisticated these days
he's 10.
charlie i'm going to go oh no you two
need to talk i'll call you tomorrow i'm
sorry to hear about you and your wife oh
come on you leaving isn't gonna bring
him back together again
look okay this is just until things
settle out a couple of days max she will
come to her senses
yeah that's what women do
look you can have the guest room i'll
grab some sheets oh that's okay
i brought my own
you brought your own sheets
i like my sheets
okay then goodnight
no no wait wait charlie
we hardly ever talk to each other
what do you want to talk about alan
i don't know uh
i was named chiropractor of the year by
the san fernando valley chiropractic
association
okay then good night no
no charlie charlie what about you what's
uh
what's going on with you
well alan there's not much to say
i make a lot of money for doing very
little work
i sleep with beautiful women who don't
ask about my feelings
i drive a jag i live at the beach and
sometimes in the middle of the day for
no reason at all i like to make myself a
big pitcher of margaritas and take a nap
out on the sunday
huh
okay then good night charlie good night
good night monkey man
boy
is your eye red
you should see it from in here
you